HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION TO THE PANDEMIC WE ARE
CONTINUING TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE- HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
HEARING IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASK THE WARRANT AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCE BE RETAINED
BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK ONE CAN BE
PROVIDED FOR YOU. I HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WITH LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DENSEST ING UPON LEAVING THE
HEARING ROOM INCLUDING
LIMITING. ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AS WE HAVE
ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS.
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU ARE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
EIGHT. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. NOW I'D
LIKE TO GO OVER A FEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP STATE WILL TAKE
NO MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR WITH CONCERNS. THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH TO REVIVE THEIR TESTIMONY
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON OUR PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR TODAY FILE ITEM TO
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY TWO AUTHORED
BY THE COMMITTEE AND FILE ITEM
THREE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
ALSO AUTHORED BY THE COMMITTEE.
FINALLY AB NINE FORTY SIX FILE
ITEM FOR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. TO A
QUORUM IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. MS HIGH LINDA WELCOME
BACK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BURKE
HERE BURKE HERE PLAN. WHEN HERE
GREAT GRAYSON GRAYSON HERE
LEVINE MAYES MIDDLETON LEVINE
EXCUSING LIVING. I EXCUSE ME
SIR. MAYES MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS. PITCHING HERE.
RIVAS SAID TOUGH YOUR THERE TO
HEAR- QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THIS IS
COUNTIES TO GO. BUT DENIAL
COOLEY TOOK COUPLE MARKETING.
THANK YOU MEDICARE THING
CALLING ON DISAPPOINTED ONLINE
MIGHT BE HERE- BUT- IT WAS A
FORMER MEMBER MEASURE HENRY
HOLLY. YEAH IF THAT'S
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW WE NEED MORE
AREAS FOR PUBLIC RECREATION WE
ALSO NEED LANCE TO HELP PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY AND ENSURE THE
STATE CAN BECOME MORE RESILIENT
TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AB TWELVE NINETEEN WOULD
REINSTATE THE REINSTATE THE
VOLUNTARY NATURAL HERITAGE
PRESERVATION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD SAVE THE LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES OF THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR A
QUALIFIED NONPROFIT WHEN
ACQUIRING PARK IN HABIT AND
HABITAT LANDS. CALIPHATE
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAMS THE SHE'S
ME CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM SUNSET
LAST YEAR THE NET EFFECT OF THE
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IS TO LOWER
THE COST TO THE STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT A 55% OF WHAT IT
WOULD PAY IN AN ALL CASH
TRANSACTION WHY WOULD A
LANDOWNER WANTED TAX CREDIT
RATHER THAN CASH THIS PROGRAM
IS UNIQUE IN ONLY WORKS UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES IT IS
MOST APPROPRIATE WHEN THERE'S A
CONVERSATION THE CONSERVATION
MINDED LANDOWNERS THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT TAX LIABILITIES.
THIS PROGRAM IS A TOOL TO SAVE
STATE AND LOCAL MONEY AND
PROVIDE MORE VALUE FOR EACH
BOND THAT DOLLARS SPENT FOR
WHEN IT WORKS FOR A WILLING
LANDOWNER AND THE LAW REQUIRES
THAT THE GENERAL FUND BE
REIMBURSED FOR THE COST OF THE
TAX CREDIT IN THE TRYING FISCAL
TIMES SOLUTION SUCH AS THESE
THAT ALLOW LIMITED RESOURCES TO
BE STRETCHED FURTHER ARE THE
TYPES OF SOLUTIONS WE SHOULD BE
SEEKING I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
AN AYE VOTE. THE SECOND. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH LUIS FONSI FOURS BURKE
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
SORRY MA'AM. WE'RE BUTCHERING
NAMES TODAY APPARENTLY. THE
CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME IS
BOOKMARKED BURKE AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WE'RE SPONSORING EIGHTY TWELVE
NINETEEN. ELLERY ESTABLISHES
THE NATURAL HERITAGE
PRESERVATION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
ALLOWING THE STATE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ARE QUALIFIED
NONPROFIT TO ACQUIRE
CONSERVATION LAND I JUST OVER
HALF THE APPRAISED VALUE BY
STRUCTURE THE ACQUISITION THE
LANDOWNER CAN RECEIVE A STATE
TAX CREDIT. PROGRAM PROVIDES
IMPORTANT BENEFITS I WOULD
REDUCE COSTS TO THE STATE.
FOURTEEN STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE THE MORE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM. UNDER ALL
PROGRAMS TAX CREDITS ARE
PROVIDED TO DONORS WITH PLANS
TO STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OR NONPROFITS FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES. AS A RESULT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES STATE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROTECT MILLIONS OF ACRES OF
HABITAT MICHAEL CULTURALLY AND
AT A LOWER COST THAN WOULD BE
REQUIRED HAVE TO SPEAK PURCHASE
SOMETHING OR EVEN. AT. THE FULL
APPRAISED VALUE. BUT IT PROGRAM
WITH THE MISSION IMPLEMENT INTO
THAT AND ONE TO HELP. AND TEXAS
PHONE WAS IN FOUR A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS PROTECT CREDIT.
ON THE DONATION OF MORE THAN
NINETY ACRES OF PART PLAN SO
SPACE WILDLIFE. CALIFORNIA FOR
ELIGIBLE COMP. MAN ACCOMPLISH.
ALLOWED COUNTRY BORDER. THE
REQUIRED APPLICANTS EXPLAIN THE
TONY. HOW THE DONATION. ONE OF
THE PROGRAMS BY COMPETITION
CRITERIA. PROGRAM ALSO REQUIRED
TO START THE FUNDS TO REIMBURSE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE- OF THE
ISSUE TAX CREDIT. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED MORE ACCESS TO
PUBLIC RECREATION. WE NEED LAND
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY HEAD
WELCOME SURE THAT THE STATE CAN
BECOME MORE RESILIENT TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. AB
TALK NINETEEN WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
HAVE AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
CONSERVATION AT THE STATE MONEY
BY TOUCHING EACH DOLLARS BACK.
WE THINK OF A NUMBER BERMAN FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE ANY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
I'M ASSUMING
THERE'S NONE. ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON TASHA NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS- THE
PLAN FOR OPEN SPACE TRUST THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACES
ALREADY AND THE MOJAVE DESERT
LAND TRUST IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS CUTE GREAT
THANK YOU AND IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY AS PART IN
VIA THE REMOTE VIDEO STATION AT
THIS TIME. SEEING NONE I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AS WELL WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE MAINLINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY PLEASE.
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THAT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE TO BY PHONE.
GREAT AND IS THERE ANYONE
PROPOSITION IN THE REVIEW VIDEO
REMOTE. NOPE SAYING NONE I SEE
NO ONE IN THE ROOM- QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ANYONE ANYONE GOOD.
MR BERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
WITH THAT MISSILE MAY CALL THE
ROLL- OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. BURKE
WHEN I GRAY GRAYSON GRAYSON I
LEVINE LEVINE I AM MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS ACT PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK RIVAS CERAKOTE ALL
RIGHT. THEY ARE TO ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE SIX VOTES SEVEN OUT. DOES
RIGHT AT THIS POINT WILL MOVE
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR OR
TODAY WHICH INCLUDE FILE ITEM
TO AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND
FILE ITEM THREE AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THERE TO COMMIT
THOSE ARE TWO COMMITTEE BILLS
TO MOVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
BURGER KING TO BOTH. THIS
HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL GRAYSON
AND LIVING. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BURKE AYE BURKE AYE
WHEN I GRAY GRAYSON OR GREYSON
AYE LEVINE LEVINE LEVINE. I'M
SORRY I DON'T REMEMBER BY THAT
NAME AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S-
THIRTY YEARS AGO THE VOTE USED
TO LIVE HERE LEVINE. LEVINE
WILL LEVINE. WE'RE GONNA. I
WILL GO TO WE'RE GETTING AS I
PROMISE WE'RE GONNA WORK ON.
MAYES MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK RIVAS
SARATOGA MICHIGAN BENDING DOWN
RIGHT HI SEE ALSO HI WE HAVE
SIX FOOT SIX ROADS CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT THE LAST ITEM
ON OUR AGENDA IS FILE ITEM FIVE
AB FIVE NINETY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND TO ADD. MEMBERS BEFORE I
BEGIN MY PRESENTATION I WOULD
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH
CLARIFY THE TERMS USED IN THE
BELL. WHEN I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AFTER WORKING
WITH ME IN MY OFFICE. ON NOT ON
THE BALLOT AS IT'S MOVED
FORWARD FROM THE BILL. THANK
YOU. AT SIGNATURE MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR. AB FIVE NINETY
THREE THE GOLDEN STATE
INNOVATION ACT BOB THIS BILL
WILL RESTORE THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT. AND NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTIONS FOR
LIFE SCIENCES COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TAX YEARS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AT THE R&D TAX CREDIT IS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
POLICY LEVERS THAT WE CAN PULL
TO ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT AND
GROWTH IN CALIFORNIA'S
INNOVATION. HANAMI ON THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL IS TO INCENTIVIZE
INVESTMENT CREATE GOOD JOBS AND
FUEL ECONOMIC GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA ALL IMPORTANT LIFE
SCIENCES SECTOR. CALIFORNIA'S
LIFE SCIENCES INDUSTRY TO BE
CLEAR IS ALREADY A CRITICAL
ENGINE. AS OUR ECONOMY LAST
YEAR ALONE THIS SECTOR DIRECTLY
EMPLOYS. MORE THAN THREE OR
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND A DIRECTLY AND
ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
INDIRECTLY. THESE ARE ALSO THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE DEVELOPING
THE LIFESAVING VACCINES
TREATMENTS AND THERAPIES THAT
ARE ENABLING US TO DEFEAT THE
COVERED NINETEEN. PANDEMIC AND
PUT THIS NIGHTMARE BEHIND US.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD THERE IS
ALSO A HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR
GROWTH IN THE LIFE SCIENCES
SECTOR. OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
THIS INDUSTRY HAS EXPERIENCED
STRONG CONSISTENT GROWTH. AND
WE THAT'S EXPECTED TO CONTINUE
AND ACCELERATE TO BE CLEAR WE
WENT BACK WITH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT THOSE JOBS
HERE WE WANT THIS INNOVATORS
HERE- WE WANT THAT ECONOMIC
OUTPUT. HERE BY REINSTATING THE
R&D TAX CREDIT AND AT THAT
OPPORTUNE LISTED OPTIONS FOR
LIFE SCIENCES COMPANIES. AB
FIVE NINETY THREE WILL FUEL JOB
GROWTH AND INNOVATION. AND.
HELP US SET CALIFORNIA ON A
ROBUST PATH TO RECOVERY. WITH
THAT I AM I PLEASE TO AND- TO
YOU WOULDN'T. FOR TESTIMONY. I
BELIEVE WE'RE JOINED BY OLIVER
CRYING AND MATT HORTON.
MODERATOR IF YOU CONNECT AS
WITH ALL OVER RID CRY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION PLEASE. DO YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ALL OF ROB ROY CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
THE PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS KIND OF VIACOM AND
BIO- I WON'T REITERATE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID WE WANT TO
THANK HER FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL A COUPLE KEY POINTS. THE
UNITED STATES LEADS THE WORLD
IN LIFE SCIENCES INNOVATION. U.
S. HEADQUARTERED ENTERPRISES
ACCOUNTED 4402% OF NEW CHEMICAL
DRUGS- INTRODUCED ACROSS THE
WORLD THAT IS MORE THAN THE
NEXT FIVE NATIONS SWITZERLAND
JAPAN THE UNITED KINGDOM
GERMANY AND FRANCE COMBINED.
THERE IS A REASON FOR THAT
INNOVATION IN THAT LEADERSHIP
CALIFORNIA THE BIRTHPLACE OF
BIOTECHNOLOGY- IT WAS- THE RD
CREDITS THAT EXISTED HELPED
FUEL THAT GROWTH- ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE UNITED STATES
LEADS THE WORLD AND DEVELOPING
NEW MEDICINES IS BECAUSE OF AN
INVESTMENT THE UNITED STATES
FIRST INTRODUCED. THE WORLD'S
FIRST RD TAX CREDIT NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE AND SINCE THEN WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN OUR
LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE GLOBE
CALIFORNIA IS PROUD TO LEAD THE
NATION- THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WORK OUT WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU WITH THE MY PUT
CONNECT US NOW WITH MATT HORTON
OF THE MILKEN INSTITUTE. YEAH
RIGHT NOW I'M SURE THIS IS MATT
HARDY CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU. PERFECT I'M NOT USED
TO I'M USED TO DO NOT TO.
CONFERENCE CALL- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR- ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK AND THEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- FROM- EXPERT WITNESS
STANDPOINT- THE- THE- R TAX
CREDIT HERE IS ISRAEL IS VERY-
REFLECTED IN PAST RESEARCH THE
INSTITUTE OF CONDUCTED. ALL THE
WAY BACK TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IN TERMS OF. THAT KEY
COMPONENT IN THE STATE'S
REGIONAL INNOVATION LIFECYCLE
AS GENERATING- OUR GROWTH AND
SECTOR GROWTH AROUND THE STATE-
THE BIOTECH LIFE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY ALREADY SUPPORTS AND
HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT- REALLY CRITICAL JOB
AND- JOB INTENSITY IT IN AND
AROUND THE STATE- LEGALESE
JOBS- DOWNSTREAM ARE CRITICAL
IN SUPPORT- HIGHER. HIGHER
WAGES AND THEN HIGHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
ESPECIALLY IN BUT INVOLVED IN
IT AND BIOTECH AND LIFE
SCIENCES- FROM A SECTOR-
PROMOTIONAL EQUITY DEVELOPMENT
STANDPOINT. PLACES THAT THE
DEBATE- JOBS IN BIOTECH AND
LIFE SCIENCES- OFFER MORE
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES AND
DEVELOPMENT FROM A JOB
INTENSITY STANDPOINT. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO COUPLE THAT
JOB INTENSITY IN AND AROUND OUR
HI HIGH GROWTH AREAS OF- AROUND
UNIVERSITIES AND HIGHER
EDUCATION OFFER EVEN MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR- REGIONAL AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND PARTS
OF THE- STATE THAT ARE-
SOMEWHAT LEFT BEHIND SO- FROM-
FROM A RESEARCH STANDPOINT AND
LOOK AND- PERSPECTIVES THE FIVE
NINETY THREE REALLY ALIGNS WITH
SOME OF OUR CORE. INSIGHTS ON
ON HOW THE RD TAX CREDIT IS A
VITAL COMPONENT TO- CONTINUING
CALIFORNIA'S- LEADERSHIP IN.
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY
GROWTH. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL IN SUPPORT YOUR- AND
IF. WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO TO THE
PHONE LINES YES PLEASE. THANK
YOU- TO STATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WELL FIRST A
LINE TWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE NEXT WE HAVE LINE TWENTY
TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON THE AFTER THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
AB MATT APOLOGIZED LIKE IN
LETTER AND IN TIME BUT WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING
OUTLINED TWENTY ONE TO ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ADAM CARE MEMBERS
CAN BE JACKSON VIACOM
CALIFORNIA PROUD SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FOR THE LINES IN Q. GREAT THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN THE VIDEO
TELECONFERENCING CENTER. SEEING
NONE I SEE NONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- MODERATOR FOR YOU TO OPEN
THE LINE FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE NINE THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU ANY OPPOSITION IN THE VIDEO
REMOTE CONFERENCING CENTER
SEEING NONE I SEE NINE HERE IN
THE- HEARING ROOM QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. DR
CLARK AND THEN MISTER SAM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIGNATURE ART
YES I SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND AS
I TOLD THE AUTHOR IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD HOPE
BUDGET COMMITTEE LOOKS AT. AND
FUNDS ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER
R. AND D. AND THAT OPERATING
LOSS- DEDUCTIONS THAT WERE
CANCELED IN THE LAST YEAR- I
WAS ASKED TO LOOK AT A NET
OPERATING LOSS TO IT ONLY-
REFER TO- SOLAR ENERGY PROJECTS
IT. IT REALLY WE REALLY OUGHT
TO BE DOING THIS ACROSS THE
BOARD I CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS
BUT I THINK WELL I KNOW THE
AUTHOR AGREES WITH ME ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER SEA.
BELT OF ECHO THE COMMENTS OF A-
MISTER CORK AND- ARE YOU TAKING
CO AUTHORS. CERTAINLY YES I
WOULD LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THE BILL WITH YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER START. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
NOTICING THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU WITH THAT
ENTIRELY WHEN TO CALL THE ROLL.
FINE HI BY. RIGHT LOOKING. I
MAY. HELLO YEAH HI I HAVE OVER.
FIVE SB THIS. HI THERE ARE.
THANK YOU AT SOME OF BILLS OUT
I THINK YOU MENTIONED I WILL
HOLDOVERS OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES
FOR THOSE WHO NEED ADD ON. DOT
COURT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
ADDED TO CONSENT FINAL. BURKE I
AND- AB TWO NINETEEN BERMAN
YEAH. BURKE I AM AB TWELVE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME. YEAH. AND ARE. AGENCY.
ALL RIGHT LAST CALL FOR ADD ONS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR RIVAS
RIVAS I. I AB TWELVE NINETEEN
BERMAN THAT'S A TO PASS TO
APPROACH THE BILL HAS ALREADY
PASSED RIVAS HI. AND ON AB FIVE
NINETY THREE PETRIE-NORRIS THE
BILL HAS ALREADY PASSED AND
IT'S- RIVERSIDE. WE'LL GIVE A
RUN TWO MINUTES TO COMPLETE THE
FIVE MINUTES WE GAVE THEM.
MISTER BOLAN. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MULLIN I AB TWELVE
NINETEEN THE BILL'S BEEN COSTA
APPROPRIATIONS. MULLIN I. IN AB
FIVE NINE THREE BY
PETRIE-NORRIS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MULLIN HI.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
WE WILL. YOU CAN ENTER FOR YOUR
CHANCE.